as Iowa Republicans are just minutes
away from caucusing the latest ABC News
poll is horrific news for Joe Biden his
overall approval rating is a
staggeringly low 33% and on the economy
it's even worse
31% now if Biden had an action figure it
would be called G I don't want Joe and
if his recent campaign appearances were
intended to reassure voters they were
epic
failures if you look at the consumer
confidence measures they're way up look
at across the board everybody's doing
better and they believe it they know it
and they're just beginning to sink
in really and now more than two years
later despite everything the media has
done to try to prop him up it's not just
Joe Biden's physical decline that's
evident there's chaos breaking out all
over the invasion at the southern border
has already fundamentally changed
America and of course that's what
Biden's people wanted inflation that's
dipped slightly but Americans buying
power has taken a major hit groceries
that cost you $100 in December of 2019
cost you
$125 by the end of 2023 thanks to axios
for that now over the course of the year
that adds up to real money to real
people and none of that can be messaged
Away by Karen Jean Pier by the way but
nice try meanwhile our effort to help
protect Ukraine's borders that hasn't
panned out oops what's 100 billion
dollars among friends and for a few
hours on Saturday night we wondered
whether the White House grounds their
borders were even safe a pro Palestinian
mob was trying to scale they were
rattling trying to climb over the
security fence screaming F Biden it
turns out Hamas has some friends on the
left and since they're left this they're
not going to be put in solitary
confinement and they're not going to be
charged even with simple
trespassing but I know what you're
thinking at least the Democrats have a
great
bench Biden's gonna step aside Laura and
he's gonna get someone else to step in
like who Gavin Nome oh that's hilarious
Trump would love or Des santis or anyone
would love to run against that track
record in
California why are so many successful
people leaving your state Gab
okay but what about JB pritsker a big
man for a big job we just saw him at
Starbucks down the street about an hour
ago Americans are going to vote for the
billionaire who proudly declared
Illinois a sanctuary State and then
begged Texas to stop sending
migrants we have migrants that arrive
from Texas virtually every day U
hundreds and uh we don't have places to
put them we've asked him to stop sending
people because of the
weather the weather by contrast the
Republican Party by almost every measure
is far stronger than it was after the
2022 midterms now we all know the south
is where it's at we love Iowa but the
south is where it's at for economic and
population growth people genuinely seem
to feel safer and just generally more
content there also GOP support is
growing in states where Trump lost last
time and the more Democrats try then to
put him in jail charge him Indi him the
more they Hound him the stronger he
seems to get turns out political
prosecutions don't sit well with most
fair-minded folks and Ians they're
fair-minded so the big questions tonight
first will Trump's margin of Victory be
historically High big will he get close
to
50% and if so an argument can be made
that that race this race is over second
will Nikki Haley's money translate into
turnout and the question that someone
posed to me today which I didn't have a
good answer for is she really
articulating a vision for the country
that's all that different substantively
from let's say Mitt Romney in
2012 let's keep in mind these people
that are wanting to come here they want
to come for a better life too they have
kids too they have a heart too
oh I forgot that one and if she thought
getting favorable treatment from never
trumpers like Bill Crystal and the New
York Times if that helps her high
primary chances well she's really out of
touch third question will DeSantis defy
the polls and Leap Frog over Haley
despite the big money deficit now he has
the governor's endorsement here she's
pretty popular but will that matter and
then if he finishes in let's say low
single digits will he end up dropping
out and endorsing
Trump now for his part Trump just
snagged endorsements from Marco Rubio
and Doug beram not bad they see the
writing on the wall I think and unless
something wacky happens here in cold
cold Iowa the writing on the wall seems
to be Tru MP hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else